[Music]
oh yeah
oh yeah
oh yeah let's get it going
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
everybody welcome back to ripping with
griffin
once again we're here doing the podcast
live in full effect
today we got a lot to talk about i guess
you know get caught up on the wedding
stuff
um just some real world advice from a
grown ass man is back
i saw this show comedy bebop want to
talk about it
condolences out to those school shooting
today
and
uh edc receipts it's ridiculous
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
shout out to dopa pod the dope funk band
that made that's from me and you know
here we are once again welcome back to
river with griffin and we live in full
effect on youtube we're from with
griffin doing it live
cuz that's how we do
that's how we do y'all that's how we do
keeping it live and full a
fact
that's how we do it
um
what's going on first of all i want to
say thank you for being here
uh make sure you hit the subscribe
you know subscribe for me and uh hit the
notifications so you get the live
notifications hit those likes
i see a bunch of people in here and i
don't see them likes going up the likes
help y'all you'd be surprised and
putting comments helps too you know put
a comment up hit a like especially if
you're listening um
all you people listening to apple
podcast listeners i need you to put
likes up there too that really helps
uh you know put you know give a positive
feedback and give me some likes there to
uh
you know i'm on twitch i'm a gamer i
twitch most every day uh
call of duty i love it a new call of
duty is coming out love that and if you
want to be a patreon member i got extra
bonus content coming out there too so
sign up at patreon at eric griffin
woo look at me doing all this stuff
right here so uh
yeah guys thanks for being here with
whitford griffin i got to chat live i'm
looking at y'all so i might uh
respond to some of you guys today and
we'll see what's going on there uh you
guys are a little bit behind but you
know i can see the the the stuff there
so we'll see what's going on
um yeah but my wedding is coming up you
know
wedding is coming up i'm a little bit of
a groomzilla
you know about where i want people to
sit and how we want people to uh
you know how we want how we want people
to be there the gifts uh you know just
just everything like how the ceremony is
going i'm really i'm actually really
getting into it and i uh really enjoy
that so that's um
you know that's pretty cool
that you know i feel i i'm as i step
back from myself and i go oh man that's
actually pretty dope
uh so i like that i'm you know i wasn't
sure how i was gonna be you know because
normally i'm a little bit like i don't
know i think we're doing podcasts and
stuff like that you're always analyzing
things and over analyzing and sometimes
it's just time to just like sit back and
just have some fun you know what and i
mean i'm looking forward to it i am
enjoying the the the process of leading
up to it so it is what it is y'all it is
what it is you know and yeah and y'all
you know everybody always has their rude
comments stop don't don't worry about my
business
her and i've been together five years
you know we live together it's like this
is
we have a great relationship
you know i res i i love her dearly and
it is what it is so all you people that
are with your
you know i don't know about her you know
get your get a prenup and all this kind
of stuff we we handling our own business
so don't so don't you worry about it
okay
so
just just uh mind your business okay
um
oh you know what let's uh take a moment
from the comedy podcast even though you
know y'all know i get serious sometimes
and just you know my condolences go out
too because it happened today and i'm
doing this live
to the the people of in texas uh there
was another school shooting
and
you know this one's bad like they're all
bad but this one's pretty bad you know
it's a number of students and teachers
you know the the perpetrator of some you
know let me let let's guess you know
18 year old white male i i believe you
know i don't know it's
no it's just it's sad and i actually you
know
i feel bad for
that family and this kid who was killed
you know he did he didn't survive
you know what i mean i could i could
have a little sympathy for that person's
family and and whatever led up to that
it's a sad thing you know
and i hope we don't get into another
ridiculous discussion about gun control
and that's going to go back and forth
when you know what i think we really
should be talking about let me just take
a moment to talk about just some family
values just some looking out for one
another uh you know we don't look in our
friends we don't actually reach out to
our friends enough we do it on us on the
phone but we don't really do it we don't
look in each other's eyes and uh give
each other embrace
see each other and ask hey how you doing
is everything okay
because like this shooting reminds me of
the one that was sort of racially
motivated before another 18 year old it
was like an 18 year old white male with
a manifesto on his computer and it's
like
you know why is it always the same type
of thing
what leads up to that like where's the
family man like where's the family
looking out for this kid and checking in
on him and making sure he's okay
where are his friends where's his people
at school it's not their responsibility
you know people we make people make bad
choices and they have to live with them
or they die because of them but all i'm
saying is what can we do as a society to
look out for one another to make sure
we're okay
you know we we need more we need more
interaction we need more
we just need more from each other and i
just think that we live in this society
where it's just you know we just
electronically say hello to each other
but we don't really like look at each
other and just find out hey how you
doing how easy is it to like be on your
phone and just like somebody asks you
hey somebody be like hey man how you
doing and then you just write like you
know you could be crying and be like i'm
okay but we don't really know because i
don't know i don't know that you're okay
so
i don't know man i'm not i'm not trying
to simplify it i just i just have some
sympathy right now for like
everything that's that's happening in
that place right now for all the
families that were just
devastated by this today and it's just
for everyone else it's just we have to
really like let's look out for one
another let's you know if you it's like
if you're a young person listening to my
show and you have some kid in your class
then maybe he doesn't have friends and
nobody talks to him and he's wearing all
black or you're feeling some weird vibes
maybe it's time to be like you know
you're not trying to snitch on the kid
but maybe it's time to like grab some
classmates and be like hey such and such
how are you you wanna come eat lunch
with us like it's so easy for people to
put out negativity you know that's the
internet man you know i talk about a lot
about the trolls and what people say and
it's so easy for people to like sit you
know what a keyboard warrior does and
just like
put out negativity to like reach out to
me and say mean things oh you're fat or
this and you know you're i i don't like
you it's like man does everything have
to be negative does everything have to
be negative like is there a time where
we can have like some positive
conversations with each other is there a
time that you could just be like even
even you can positively disagree with
someone you know what i mean like could
it just be like hey man i don't like
your take
uh here and here's my take or here's why
i don't like your take but it's always
the same kind of thing
oh you're stupid what an idiot what a
you know that's how like it's like
that's the negativity that people put
out and like you know some kid is out
there he doesn't know i don't know man
it's just i don't know what how to feel
i guess i do know how to feel i just
feel some sadness you know
and it's like even if
you know cause to me like racism and
that kind of stuff it's a learned
behavior
but check this out
even if you're a family
let's say you're a white family just use
it as an example and you know you don't
like minorities maybe you're like a
family living in a certain place and
you've never met black people and you
don't like them and you look at the news
and you think like ah look at and you
know you're teaching your kids that i
don't agree with it but you're like hey
yeah we don't like these people because
of this this and that i still think
you
that person
wouldn't want their kid to go out and
murder people and get shot by the police
or kill themselves
even if your philosophy is some negative
philosophy i don't agree with there's
still some family values
excuse me i just want to see that that
was like a spit there's still some
family values i think that even you
would want your kids to have that they
stay alive
that they try to be happy
you know what i mean
uh so i don't know it's uh
it it's it's crazy uh it's crazy out
there so you know and even as i'm saying
this
there's still like a troll idiot in my
chat
saying some stuff that's like you know
even in a time like this you know what i
mean so i'm glad you i'm glad you did
that dude i really appreciate so i'm
going to
uh block you and hide you from my
channel forever and i i wish you all the
best in your life and uh you know good
luck with everything and i hope that you
know you i hope the negativity works out
for you you know what i mean
i hope that negativity works out for you
uh and good luck with your life uh
abraham t
uh who all he has to say is negative
stuff so i mean there's someone that's
what i'm saying right there even in the
midst of me talking about this there's
people that have to be
mean negative [ __ ] so love and
energy goes out to that guy i hope your
life gets better for you uh but anyways
like i say man just to close i don't
want to keep talking about this but i
just my heart goes out to those people
and you know i hope that we don't get
bogged down with a political discussion
about gun control again because
to me that that's a separate
conversation from
uh you know
looking out for one another
you know
making sure people are okay
uh family values
uh you know making sure that like you
know before someone turns 18 that
that whatever we're gonna instill in our
young people that it's more of a
positivity
uh in their lives and and we can all
help one another man uh you know because
it doesn't always have to be the extreme
in terms of like a school shooting i
mean maybe it's just somebody that's
just down and not feeling themselves
today maybe it's like your neighbor your
co-worker or you know we all don't know
about what's going on in our lives you
know what i mean there's always
something going on in everyone's life
that we don't know so maybe it's time
that we take a moment sometimes just to
be like hey
just look at each other and be like are
you okay
i'm just asking i want to make sure
you're okay and that's what i'm saying
out to you guys right now as i look
right into the camera and i ask all of
you right now how are you
i hope you're okay and i wish you all
the best
all right guys um
enough of that right
so
um i i don't know what
edc is
you know what i mean
i don't know what that is uh oh you know
what let's actually let me actually say
this to uh
make sure you check me out uh if you're
in the arlington texas area you know you
need some laughs you know come on out
and see me i'm at the arlington improv
this weekend starting to friday so
friday saturday sunday i'm at the
arlington improv you can get tickets
right now
at the improv or you can go to my
website eric griffin.com and i got a
link to the tickets so you know you
might want to go check that out uh if
you want to check me out you want to see
me live i'm out here doing it man i'm
out here live so check me out so i don't
know what edc festival is y'all uh let's
let's actually look it up it's like the
electronic what's it called
it's the
electronic daisy carnival that's what
it's called the lost las vegas daisy
carnival edc right
so you know yeah i don't know what this
is this is probably music that i don't
like
but i mean i don't hate it i i shouldn't
even say that it's just probably it's
just not my scene this is one of those
times where i feel 50 i don't know
what's going on with this and it's not
like it's like coachella like i don't go
to coachella but i have it's funny thing
is i've been in vegas
during this edc
uh electronic daisy carnival i've been
there i've been but like just in vegas
at the same time and it always blows me
away like like how people are dressed
it's like some sort of halloween
carnival or something right but like the
way people are dressed man
like practically butt ass naked and
vegas is already crazy like that but
when the edc thing is going on you will
see a chick with just panties on panties
and like gummy bears on our nipples you
know what i mean like big gummy bears
taped her nipples and panties just
walking around and you just kind of like
okay
and it's like you know obviously it's
young people you know what i mean like
not they're in vegas so they got to be
21 and up but you know at the car at the
festival they could be eight it could be
any age you don't even know but you just
walking around like whoa what's going on
here you know what i mean and it's like
i don't know i guess like there's sort
of like you it's like okay in vegas to
kind of be like kind of gawking like hey
look at that oh wow look at this you
know because like you know people will
be like and then it's like i remember
when i was there it's like these like
are very like very workaholics fandom
kind of like overlap with edc so it was
like i'm walking around just trying to
go play craps and you know and people
like you know
[ __ ] it clearly on acid or something
just kind of like munches
oh man
dad let's take pictures you know it's
like these young people half naked you
know want to take pictures and stuff and
i'm just kind of like man what is going
on
so they got this festival every single
year uh they just had it um and make
sure you check out jen the gen podcast
because boy matthew espinoza he goes
every single year one year we were there
together and i i we were trying to link
up but he because he was like dude you
got to come to this thing and i'm like i
ain't going you know what i mean because
he's young and he's over there doing
young people stuff so i don't know what
goes on i don't know the music i mean as
i look at the lineup let's say you know
we look at the lineup you know it's like
i don't know who any of these people are
i mean look at some of these names man i
don't know these people 1991
a tracks you know look at how many
people were here are these like djs or
these groups i don't know is this is
this like am i an old man looking at
this like look at some of these names
b2b born dirty this is a group name uh
shout out to kaizo and uh vintage
culture and ac slater b2b chris lorenz
who are these people the crime family
you know
this is like
you know what i mean like i i don't know
what like zed
zed's dead
zomboy like these are all these sort of
like electronic music artists and uh hey
no no shade on their art form because
everybody like not everybody's not
everybody's everybody's cup of tea you
know what i mean
so you know they had the music festival
um
and but this is the thing they were
showing
um like what just happened what happened
to my
oh here it is oops sorry but they were
showing like um
[Music]
uh people's receipts man so look at this
so like people would buy tables
at edc okay so they buy like a like a
table while the festival's going on
right edc las vegas look at this receipt
167
764 dollars and 50 cents let me say it
again look at this receipt y'all
167
764 and 50 cents to sit at some table
listening to
electric
dance music
man are you kidding me
look at this receipt
i don't drink alcohol y'all
but let's just talk about
the water bucket
39 water bottles
2
925
what
what
the water
to let me say it again 2
925
for the water man
uh
look at the red bull bucket
16 red bulls
112 no i'm sorry
twelve hundred dollars
red bulls for seventy five dollars a can
what's happening
so i don't even know what this other
stuff is
like i don't know what ace of spades
brute is
that it needs to cost 23 000
or how about this class azul
reposado
what is that chat can somebody tell me
what that is that cost
51 000
uh here's another receipt y'all just
another receipt for edc las vegas right
and this one i can't i can't make it
bigger but this one is 277
519.39
y'all
um
yeah you can't read this one as well as
the other one but
i mean
damn they bought something that was a
hundred thousand dollars i mean
i don't know what this is is that
tequila
is it
uh
what is the space tea bucket that cost
75
or the all are welcome what's all are
welcome for eleven thousand dollars
y'all
pj rose mag what is that thirty five
hundred dollars and then uh good for
this the service charge was ten thousand
dollars uh okay so that's the
administration fee so they charged an
administration fee of ten thousand
dollars and then the service charge the
twenty percent did this go to the waiter
did the waiter are they splitting the
tips because the waiter got and i'm sure
it was some beautiful somebody you know
what i mean they got a business card
because this is bottle service for 24
000
i hope they got that tip more power to
you but damn y'all
damn
what
i'm trying to think of the most
expensive
bill
i've ever
paid for
i don't even know i think i think you
know what i want to like an expensive
thing i paid for
i went okay so i was meeting up with
some buddies from from high school
this was a couple years ago so we all
old now everybody got glasses and a lot
of them are married and you know what i
mean so we all meet up like 15 of us we
meet up and we go to this restaurant by
the staples center you know we sitting
in there just catching up like
remembering stories playing basketball
remembering teachers remembering the
dean of students and r.i.p out to terry
matthews my dean of students he was a
bad [ __ ] man so he just passed
away
uh and so shout out to him he was a
really good man um
you know
you know we're just sitting around
reminiscing and so then like you know
you kind of you kind of feeling yourself
a little bit because it's almost like a
high school reunion you know we're just
a bunch of our guys and everybody's kind
of like what do you do now this guy oh
i'm real estate this one's that and you
can tell some people are doing well some
people are doing more than better than
others you know one of my one friends
he's still like you know he's you could
tell he's like that dude in his full
late 40s still single dating a 24 year
old he so there was that guy
you know what i mean and it was like you
know so then and and the bill comes and
i'm like oh i'm the dude on tv so i
grabbed a check and i'm like i got it
[Laughter]
everybody been drinking and buying
steaks and that kind of stuff didn't
even look at the check i was just like i
got it threw the credit card down
[Laughter]
but you know and then it was just like
the total floss move and then like
somebody you know comes like yo man come
on eric you don't got to do that then i
go it's cool y'all you know i'm on tv
stupid
man you know what i mean
just
absolutely ridiculous flossing thing to
say is don't worry about i got it daddy
on tv y'all pal credit card damn didn't
even look at it till like like you know
later like you know i check in uh i look
in my you know the phone i look at you
know checking the credit card and i'm
like god damn griffin why'd you do that
but you know what it is what it is it's
one of those experiences that later you
could tell on a podcast
you know what i mean so it's like i
don't know
and i used to do that before i remember
when i was coming up as a comic you know
i would maybe
you know i'll be on i i just got on
workaholics and whatever and then it was
like season three or four and some money
was coming in better i was like damn
it's good i moved so sometimes like the
comics we'd hang out we go to one on one
cafe after the comedy store and it's
like everybody's at different levels
doing things and the bill is like you
know it's like six of us eating you know
what i mean so then it'll be like i'll
be right back y'all you know and i would
just go pay the bill then i would just
take off you know the waitress would go
back and be like yeah he paid the bill
and left y'all and then you know it's
like your friends would hit you up like
yo man thanks that was like you know and
it's just like i don't know i just i
don't mind doing that with you know with
my friends um sometimes you know
whatever whatever it is because it's
just like there's something about that
shared experience
that shared experience at you know
when you go out after something special
and just to be like here you go man you
know you want you just want to pay i
don't know maybe there's some kind of
ego thing to it too that you make
yourself feel good that everybody
everybody's like i don't know what it is
but i as long as it comes from a good
place i'm cool so you tell me chat where
you guys what's up in the chat here you
know let me know in the comments what's
the most expensive meal
or what's the most expensive tab you
picked up you know where like you were
out at maybe you were at a hotel and it
was your friends and family and you were
like i got it or you know what you know
let me know man
anybody ever spent over a thousand at
dinner for a bunch of people you know
that's like uh and if you like one of
these rich rich folks you know even
still even for people like that you know
i know some people do like a little
thing where like you're going out with
your friends and you everybody wants to
stay connected so you put your phone in
the middle of the table and you're not
supposed to touch it and whoever can't
resist touching their phone they pay the
bill you know so i see some people in
here already jdog said he spent five
hundred dollars sometime michael mendoza
said he spent six hundred dollars at the
water grill in downtown l.a whoo that
one's a lot actually check this one i i
got a recent one i just did so i don't
know if you guys know this but rick
glassman and shout out to rick and take
your shoes off i'm on this episode of
taking shoes off this week rick and i
were in cleveland together we did an
episode out at his parents house and i
had the greatest time with rick and his
family i love me some rick glassman you
know i really do he's just really one of
my best friends and
rick is actually going to be the
officiant at my wedding that's how much
i love rick my girl loves rick too
so rick's going to be the officiant at
my wedding so we wanted to meet up so we
went to this place
shout out to vibratos it's this dope
jazz club in bel air
um
they got they have a dinner show so you
have to pay for the tickets for the show
and then you have to pay for dinner and
the dinner is boom so rick came it was
me rick and rachel and we just wanted to
discuss like what we want to do at the
wedding and this kind of stuff
and oh and before i even do that let's
oh oops oops oops make sure i i should
do this because this is rachel update
the um
and so like rachel was like well we
should take rick to dinner and i was
like all right
and so
it was like over 500 hours
that's and it was like because we all
like
i got a steak she got a steak i think he
got a steak and then rick is picky as
hell so rick will be like i need this
and i would like an appetizer but no no
this on it no that on it can you please
that do you have this in the bag can you
guess barbecue sauce can you you know
wreck record like when you order with
rick it's a little freaking production
so then you know 500 500 dinner so you
know and i like eating like that you
know i even took
when i uh
remember did i guys tell you the story
about how i went out i took wiggy to
dinner
and we went to like boa and he got sick
that dinner was 300 and he threw it all
up in my car the bastard so
um
yeah
if you know if i'm on drop if i'm gonna
drop dinner drop money on dinner it's
gonna be
i just i don't mind you know what i mean
i ain't going out to dinner with any of
y'all but i don't mind so
somebody else did 175 bought my ex fam
his ex family dinner that's a that's a
good one
you know you know especially when you
got a lot of people there so let me know
in the comments y'all write down uh
what's going on there
all right um let's uh what are we gonna
do
next
and shout out to my new producer kristen
um
you know she she gave me a bunch of
stuff to talk about so i love how that
she does this even though i don't even
really follow it sometimes but i need to
start doing that as i look at it but i
do it live so when i do it like when i
start yeah so she had me i talked about
being groomed zilla sometimes i am a
groom zilla about it uh but that's
really fun um
yeah some of these other things i'll
talk about next week but let's go into
[Music]
one of my favorite segments
real world advice from a grown ass man
is back y'all real world advice from a
grown ass man
so i got some good ones this week and
anybody else that wants to send me some
real world advice if you have a question
you want me to like discuss or something
you want to discuss that you want me to
talk about i usually do it on instagram
you can find me at eric griffin on
instagram
i like put like one of those questions
up in the story then i let people tell
me the things and then i use those
as a way of doing the real world advice
but if you really want to send me an
email you can too you can send me an
email but don't but please wait till i i
announce it so you still gotta check my
instagram because but i need to start
being more i'm gonna start
keeping track of that better okay but
let's go first up real world advice from
a grown ass man
i love this one because i was talking
about marriage so let's talk about this
one because this one is
so important i think
got married a month ago no kids were
allowed sister-in-law is still mad about
that
well let me tell you something
we got a no kids wedding going on too
i don't find any problem with this at
all
you either have
a kids allowed wedding or not if you
want to have an adult wedding i have no
problem with that i think both ways are
fine and i think it's one of those
things where you just have to let them
do people don't have children they are
oftentimes super selfish about that they
think that that you know well i have a
kid so my kid is allowed to do go
everywhere and do everything because
it's my kid and you just have to deal
with it now sometimes
you know sometimes we don't want to deal
with your kid i didn't enjoy making your
kid so why do i have to deal with your
kid you know what i mean so i don't
think there's anything wrong with this
if you want to have a adults only
wedding
uh you know you just have to like bring
you have to do that way ahead of time
you got to tell people with kids ahead
of time like babies and stuff like
little little toddlers like yeah we try
not to have toddlers at the wedding all
right we don't want baby crying during
the vows we don't want you to have to
sit we want we also want the people
there to just enjoy
being out having an adult time
without worrying about oh we got to go
change the diapers and all this kind of
stuff so it's for you too so
in terms of this question i know that
your sister-in-law is still mad but
she's probably mad too because your
sister is being taken over by some man
but it is what it is
she'll get over it just kill her with
kindness
and i'm telling you she'll eventually
get over that and good luck
all right next up y'all with real world
advice from a corners man
how to get over someone you're obsessed
with
time
get under someone else
i mean yeah
um i think this is like for sure
uh one of the things like you know i
think it's
i think we all have like been obsessed
with someone and like so my advice about
this is
like
don't get obsessed with someone
you know what i'm saying like don't get
obsessed with someone without taking
action so that's what i'm saying like if
it's someone from like you know if let's
say you like you want to take out a
co-worker or someone like
you you know
you casually know someone that you're
just kind of like oh i really like this
person so what i'm saying is my advice
is like make your move make your
intentions known before you get to the
point where you're like obsessed because
now you're filling everything in with
fantasy like when you're obsessed with
someone you don't really know anything
about them
you've made up this character in your
head that you think they are go find out
who they really are take a chance
you know or if you've or if you try to
get with someone and they just not
interested or it didn't work out but
you're still obsessed
you got to move on
move on by i always say self-care
start working on you
hang out with friends and family you
know do hobbies work on goals so you can
distract yourself from that so you can
start to feel better and you know they
always say what makes you get over the
last one is the next one i mean there is
something about like
when you lose like say you when you
break up and you lose intimacy with
someone and that intimacy is gone that
you're used to having all the time and
you start to feel like well maybe i'll
never be with someone again maybe i'll
never love anyone again and then like
you know you're just like you get into
this rut but then it's like the next one
that comes along and you have that
intimacy with someone else you start to
go oh yeah i can be with someone else oh
this was good in a way that this other
one wasn't or it was different or you
feel like i got my groove back you know
whatever it is that you're feeling i
think that it's important to
you know
get out there again so that is one way
to get over someone is like you say the
next so good luck with
that
all right
next up in the house
um i'm 31 and i have a lot of family
pressure to get married
girls i date don't seem to want to
commit
all right so i see that and i just look
at the sentence and i say to myself well
you already got your answer man
you know what i
mean it's like you got your answer
the girls i date don't seem to want to
commit
so start dating girls that want to
commit you know what i mean
it's like to me it just seems like it's
it just seems like it's that simple to
me you know
and maybe
i'm i'm i'm super i'm you know
simplifying the issue
but
you know i don't think so you know i
think it's just one of these things
where it's like you know if you if
you're if you're trying to
who what kind of person do you want to
be with you know what i mean like what
kind of person is the person that you're
like oh this is the kind of person i
want to stay with for the rest of my
life or and what kind of person is that
and i think you just got to start asking
yourself
you know
the superficial things that i like the
shallow things that i like if you're
just going for looks or if you're going
for people who are like considerably
younger than you or you're going for
some young person that still likes to
party and do all this kind of stuff well
you got to ask yourself like well damn
maybe before i get even serious with
that person let me find out if they're
on the same level as me of the of the
goals and things that i want so i mean i
just feel like
i just feel like you know if you want
girls that want commitment they're out
there but you don't seem to like attract
those type of women so you got to start
looking at yourself and being like well
let me start so then start acting like a
person that wants commitment don't act
like a person that initially like oh i'm
just trying to smash and then you go you
know what after smashing for a couple
months i realize i like you more than i
thought okay that's not how you going
sometimes that works but i think from
jump take people out on dates take them
out on two three four dates do fun
things with them get to know them get to
like them before you decide
you know once you already have the
checkbox in your head i'm attracted to
this person i would smash
get that out of your head don't make
that the minimum standard get it out of
your head like okay that check
now what
oh now is this person fun to be around
does this person want to ask questions
about me do they have goals do they have
like you know find out that stuff in the
process of finding out that stuff you
might realize oh this is a person that's
not into commitment they're not really
looking for what i'm looking for then
you move on or you know what that is and
you keep it like that but you know you
can get what you want if you put the
energy out there of what you're looking
for and just my advice is act like a
person that wants to commit
and people that want to commit will
reciprocate that energy
good luck my friend
next up y'all
all
right my boyfriend's mom is coming to
stay with us for two weeks from costa
rica and she hates me
well
first of all stop with that energy you
know just stop right there with that
energy um i know we think people you
know sometimes i sometimes i i get that
i know you i know you you sit and you go
you feel that's what you feel but
instead of like making it about you and
how you feel about it i think you should
ask yourself
why
do you think the mom hates you and and i
don't think that it's even real i think
that that's we kind of manifest that we
kind of say that but it's not really
real i mean
is the mom close to the sun because
because the mom
she probably just wants what's best for
her son you know what i mean and there's
probably no woman that's good enough so
you're you can either take the approach
of like i want to show this mom
how i take care of him how i make him
feel good about himself how i make his
life better show the mom look how happy
your son is because of me
and then i think she will appreciate you
you know because like
when we say that because i think we we
all are possessive about our friends and
family you know it's like you have your
best friend gets a girlfriend and you
kind of like hey i lost my friend and
for that chick you know what i mean it's
like we all have this sort of possessive
selfishness about ourselves
and so especially with a mother-son
relationship that's a that's a really
strong bond so i think you just want to
show the mom like i'm really taking care
of him you know what i mean whatever
that means what are what is the mom's
values like what you know
approach to mom like that go to her and
be like mom like you know mother like
like hey uh i really love your son and
i'm you know
get her advice you know what like what
you know what does he like and like i
want to cook for him what did you cook
from i want to do this say you know what
i'm saying like just whatever it might
be you know it doesn't have to be that
stuff i'm just using that as an example
but
you know the moms are
you know you don't don't just write mom
off like she hates you you know just
think of it as like mom's just
protective of her son
and i think you can overcome this and
you can show her that you you got what
it takes
just keep that as your goal and i think
you'll be okay
all right next up
my girl and i are moving 800 miles away
from family friends and our jobs
to kind of start over advice well i
don't mean i don't know how if you're
moving that far away how is it kind of
starting over i think you're just
starting over and my advice is you
already have your dog with you your
partner and you guys make big moves you
make big choices and big decisions
because that's what it says to me that
y'all moving to improve your life and
you decided that making this move is
important so don't worry all that other
stuff is going to fall into place i
trust me you're going to make new
friends you're going to make new hobbies
you're going to find things to do
because you're you guys are adventurous
and you're go-getters and you make big
moves so trust yourself that you're
going to make that this was the right
choice and you're going to find stuff
you're going to find people you're going
to find hobbies because look one city is
just like another city man you know you
had your favorite like if i was in la
and i'd be like oh i have my favorite
italian restaurant if i moved i'd be
like where am i gonna eat italian food
now there's another place there's a
place wherever i'm gonna move to you
know what i mean and if not there's like
a restaurant that i'm sure oh this is
gonna be even better restaurants so i
think that you're gonna be fine i think
you're gonna be fine and stop stressing
over it and just trust yourself
trust yourself you made big moves you
make big choices trust yourself
and you can always visit your family and
friends so it's not like your
relationships are over all right
good luck
next up
i didn't pass an upper division business
class and you're feeling down advice
take that [ __ ] again you know what i
mean like
you know what it's okay to be down think
of sports you needed to win that game
you lost the game maybe you didn't make
the playoffs
shake it off another year is coming and
now you know ask yourself why didn't you
pass this class did you not study enough
is it too hard are you not interested is
this like uh is it are you showing that
to yourself now you were like well i
really wasn't into it so i didn't really
study hard enough what could you have
done differently to pass that class
think about those things and improve
that for the future and maybe just also
re-evaluate is this business is this
what you really want to do and maybe you
show to yourself some consciously that
you don't really want to do it and
that's why you didn't pass the class you
know what i'm saying but
you it's okay to be down but don't let
that linger
now attack
the future what are you going to do to
improve your situation now
and once you do that then i think you're
going to
you know then then you'll be okay
because now you've moved on to something
else and that
lingering of like oh that didn't go well
it's gonna go away all right
and good luck
with
that
all right y'all
that has been
real-world advice from a grown-ass
merch
okay
uh where are we at now y'all i'll tell
you where we're at um i i want to tell
you about this show that i saw
and it's called
cowboy bebop
cowboy bebop
um
it stars let's go to the imdb together
as a family here i'm gonna go to the
imdb
yeah so here's a cowboy bebop
it's a ragtag crew of bounty hunters
chasing down the galaxy's most dangerous
criminals they'll save the world
for the right price
huh
i it's weird that that's the description
because i would say that that's not
really what the show's about um i got
mixed reviews on this one
uh it stars joncho
mustafa shakur and daniela pineda
i thought these three guys these three
people were pretty good
i thought as actors they were pretty
good
uh there they are right there
uh well there's two of them i don't know
who that one is that's somebody else
um yeah there they they go right there
so i don't know what else they've been
in
john chowi's been in the star wars and
he's actually a badass he's actually a
badass i like that you know he's you
know he's like a he could be the next
kung fu star or whatever
martial arts he does he's actually
pretty good i like him
um and danielle panetta they were good
they were good um apparently i i think
there's people that watch this that the
show that there's an anime version of
the show that that people have been
telling me i need to check out
so i probably i probably should check
that out huh the anime version um let me
see if i can look out the website anime
cowboy bee
bee oop cowboy bee bop okay so
yeah okay yeah i've never seen this and
i guess you could see it on hulu you can
see it on netflix and you can see it on
2b i guess i'll check this out because
apparently this is supposed to be
it's supposed to be really good so i
don't know
but all right so let's talk about this
series that uh i saw
um
you know i i like sci-fi
i like sci-fi adventure stuff
so this was like this was in line with
that and i would say that the first
three or four episodes it was really
good and i had high hopes
i had high hopes uh you know it wasn't a
lot of big special effects but the
special effects they had were pretty
good but i thought that as they went on
the story really got bogged down and
slow about what this about so you know
you got a spoiler alert but you got
they got this guy
um
john show who plays this character spike
spiegel
and spike spiegel has
changed his life he's now a cowboy
bounty hunter they're called cowboys
space cowboys and their bounty hunters
so he's a bounty hunter and he works
with this guy jet black played by
mustafa shakur and they're roaming
around the galaxy collecting bounties
and like earth has been abandoned and
you know they're just there's
interstellar travel now and you know
they're just warming around and it's the
same kind of stuff everything's run by
corporations and you know there's like a
tax for this a tax for that and you know
and it's like it opens up in a really
great action scene of them trying to get
this bounty in this like space casino
and it's a big fight scene and they
really set up the universe so you think
like oh this is cool it's gonna be cool
characters doing cool stuff right and so
that let's say the first few episodes
that's pretty much what it was and then
um you know so you find out that you're
finding out i would say the story this
show really is about john cho spike
spiegel who used to be in a in a vicious
mobster gang called the syndicate and
they run crime throughout the universe
and he used to be in the syndicate and
he they think he's dead and he used to
be called he used to be called fearless
and he was a hitman for the syndicate
and now he's changed his name to spike
spiegel and he's working with this guy
jet black who is a former cop turned
bounty hunter and he has his story of
how
why he is now you know
you know he had something happen he got
double crossed and there was like a
dirty cop so there's that story goes on
so eventually throughout the season you
find out
who the dirty cop was which i'm not
gonna spoil that for you i knew like
like it wasn't a i wasn't shocked when
you found out who the dirty cop was i
was like yeah of course it's that guy
they didn't do a very good job of that
and then so now
you know you you you know
this spike spiegel this guy fearless his
former partner
who's called vicious
uh and vicious is played by um alex
hazel
he's actually pretty good actor i i
liked him i believed him as this like
over-the-top cartoon villain but he
is now
he's in the syndicate
you know and he's dating this woman
uh played by elena sateen who is dope
she's very beautiful
and i and obviously
him vicious and fearless spike spiegel
they both were going for the same girl
you know you find out that that's why
they tried to have him killed
and so spike's beagle they tried to kill
him and now he came back as spike's
beagle and there's a bounty hunter and
then the syndicate finds out that he's
still alive and that's kind of like the
through line of what's going on
throughout the series and so i would say
it started really strong
you know in the first episode i thought
the pilot was good
um
it was good you know what i mean i
thought the pilot was good
i thought that
the first few episodes were good like
kind of setting up this world
and then it just it got boring i i
didn't like how it ended i i thought
that the you know episode seven eight
like
eight nine and ten
i was like
you know i don't know if it's even
coming back for another season i think
it was cancelled already uh from what
from what i hear i don't let me let's
actually let me just you know let me
just google this this the thing right
now uh you know then we'll we'll find
out
uh
cowboy bebop second season maybe
cowboy
cowboy bebop canceled by netflix after
one season yeah according to the
hollywood reporter you know and i'm not
surprised because it's probably an
expensive show to make and it probably
just didn't get a lot of views because
the special effects are pretty good the
spaceship and the and all the the the
this fake world that they're in all the
time you know so it was probably very
expensive and they just didn't want to
finish it
that so this article that was fast
netflix cancels its ambitious widely
hyped and ultimately widely
disappointing anime adaption
that's actually a great
description
better description of the show than the
description of the show
a disappointing anime adaption
so
i still say watch it
especially like watch like a first few
episodes but once you start to get into
the story of where it's going you're
gonna see what i'm saying it becomes a
little boring
but
um
i say it's worth watching
uh but yeah i don't think it ended well
so i'm only giving that maybe like two
woo-woos
yeah
so
that that's that's all i have to say
about cowboy bebop
[Laughter]
but it's like i watched it so
i wanted to
you know it's like you watch a show you
gotta i thought i felt like i liked i
like watching a show and then coming
telling you guys about it
you know because there's so many things
to watch and you know you either like
you either like my reviews and you're
like are you just like oh i gotta go
watch because i think this guy's i hate
what he says and you still end up
watching it so i'm just giving you like
some uh some some things for a show
has anybody watched any of the other
shows that i've asked you about you can
let me know in the chat anybody watched
outer range on amazon have you watched
that one and what did you guys uh think
of that one
um
and so anybody else watched cowboy bebop
is anybody in the chat right now live
watched cowboy bebop and what did you
think of it i mean like i said yeah if
you decided if you saw a couple episodes
you were like yeah man i checked out i
didn't want to watch it anymore i
totally get it but it was the kind of
thing where i sort of binged it you know
i started watching then i got to like
episode five six and i was like i kind
of i binged the whole thing in like
three days
and you know i don't feel
i didn't learn anything you know what i
mean i don't feel like oh that was so
good i don't got i don't i don't get any
kind of
feeling like that from it so
it is what it is y'all
so that's uh
that's how i feel about cowboy bebop so
if you if you uh
i'm gonna check out you know what i'm
gonna do is
i'm gonna check out the anime version
and we're gonna see if that you know if
that was
you know what i mean like if that was
like oh yeah the anime version is so
much
better but
anyways y'all
short and sweet today didn't get a full
hour in but you know
like i say once again my condolences to
all the families
of the tragedy in texas and like i said
earlier let's like let's try to be kind
again let's
look out for your friends family
neighbors co-workers
sometimes check in with them see how
they doing
uh cowboy bebop
they only got two woo-woos maybe you
should have got one woo
but yeah because there's a john woo in
it so shout out to wu he got some
boo-boos
so there's that
and
you know damn festival receipts man
that's something for the chat how much
what's the most expensive meal you've
ever paid for let me know about it put
that in the comments i want to hear
about that
uh and make sure like i said if you are
in texas arlington dallas area
i will be at the arlington improv come
get some get your tickets 27th 28th 29th
come check me out right there
in texas
make sure you subscribe y'all subscribe
for whiffer with griffin oh my mike's
too hot make sure you subscribe
uh i'm on twitch i'm about to go on
twitch after this
and if you want some extra bonus content
check me out on patreon
eric griffin
patreon.com eric griffin
you guys have been absolutely fantastic
as always
thank you for listening watching griffin
with griffin i appreciate your loyalty
and i love you
see you next week
[Music]
um
[Music]
you